[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pat 40
sports illustrated senior writer
covering college athletics and i believe
he was watching a basketball game or
something that resembled a basketball
game last night
with kansas and kentucky what's the
takeaway from
the basketball that you saw last night
they told us it was basketball i
i remain unconvinced after having been
there it was it was traumatic i mean it
was as bad as it gets kansas one
shooting 30 percent
uh both these teams are not vintage
versions of themselves i mean kansas and
kentucky usually are national
championship contenders maybe
one or both of them will round into that
form dan but they're a long way from
that now which is actually par for the
course for both of them but especially
kentucky at this time of year but
kentucky hasn't been one and two which
they are now since billy gillespie was
the coach so this is the worst start
they've had under calipari
he doesn't have the horses that he
usually has it doesn't appear
uh so his annual kind of build from
nothing to something
is going to be a little bit steeper and
more difficult this season
give me three players that we should
keep an eye on in college basketball
this year
uh three players i i think that
obviously luca garza
at iowa who put up 40-something in their
game
last week you know a lot of people
surprised he stayed in school
he's not an unbelievable athlete but boy
is he he's got skill and will he's tough
he's strong
he's relentless uh i would say jalen
suggs freshman
at uh gonzaga i think gzag is the best
team and he's the
highest recruited player they've had
there and a little bit off the radar but
cade cunningham another star freshman
he's at oklahoma state which is not
eligible for the postseason but he's
really good and he's going to be a very
high draft pick
does duke have one of those guys
yeah not really that's you know you look
at duke and you look at kentucky
and you don't see you sure don't see
zion williamson you don't see anthony
davis you don't see carl towns you know
any of those sort of guys
you see a lot of good players who are
highly recruited but i don't think you
see
somebody who is going to be a superstar
freshman and then
a you know top three pick for either
team
all right let's turn our attention to
college football you have the uh
playoff selection show week two here
there there weren't any headlines until
kirk herb street said the following
i still think michigan waves the white
flag potentially avoids playing ohio
state next week
and then david they'll potentially get a
game on the 19th
they could be sitting there with six
games and michigan is that fair david
michigan could
opt out basically of that game and keep
ohio state out
of six games to qualify for the big ten
championship that doesn't make sense to
me but i think a lot of people wanted to
see where ohio state would be
your reaction to that pat was whoa did i
just hear that i was watching it in real
time and i was like
did kirk herb street the former ohio
state quarterback just say that the arch
rival
is going to chicken out of playing one
of the biggest rivalry games in college
football
wow uh and so you know that was my
thought i immediately thought well
there's a column
and i said i started writing especially
rhys davis followed up with the
the the comment or the you know doubled
down on that and
and kirk stuck with that line basically
saying that
coaches are telling him that schools are
using covet as a
an excuse to avoid playing games they're
going to lose or be humiliated in and
then he said
i don't really know about michigan and
they later apologized for that
but what it says to me dan is everything
about the messy end of this season okay
there's a lot of people that probably
really don't want to play
there are some teams that are probably
using covet as an excuse
not to play so that that's probably true
but that was a pretty wild accusation
and it underscores the amount of
suspicion and cynicism that we are going
to be involved in for the next two or
three weeks because
we are dragging this season to the
finish line and there's a lot of players
and a lot of teams that really don't
want to be there
what is michigan status as far as being
able to play football the next two weeks
yeah they paused uh in-person
uh activities monday and tuesday don't
know whether they'll be back
on the field today wednesday so they are
tbd for this week still we'll see
you know if they can get to their game
saturday against maryland ohio state
looks like now they're going to play
after they missed last week
uh this is the kind of the the state of
the big ten right now is
is very tenuous i mean it's day to day
about who's going to play and usually if
you miss one week it could be a two-week
problem you know it looks like ohio
state may avoid that
but we will see with michigan do they
play this week and then obviously do
they play next week but also pat
i just wonder when we say well it's
based on the eye
test it's based off your resume if ohio
state only plays four or five games
i don't know how that playoff selection
committee can honestly look at them and
go
yep they're one of the four best teams
in the country
as much as we want to base this on you
know past
uh the talent they have who's the
quarterback
they they haven't done anything to
distinguish themselves
as one of the four best teams in the
country when it's all said and done
right no i mean that's the thing you'd
be looking at basically a half a resume
compared to some other schools that have
played literally twice as many games
you know brian kelly was pretty
interesting a couple of games ago made a
point when they got to eight he said we
have played a big ten schedule
he made his point pretty clear that you
know that the the different number of
games will be a major
flashpoint arguing point for the
comedian for fans everywhere and
gary barter the chair of the selection
committee did say last night that it's
close
for four between ohio state and texas a
m which is lost but has played more
games
so i think the committee is absolutely
going to look at that and i think
that's going to be a down to the wire
discussion i mean if you're ohio state
you really need to play every possible
game you can
i was also wondering could you see a
scenario where florida beats alabama
and clemson barely beats notre dame
and they would still all stay in the top
four and they would cancel out ohio
state
yeah oh i think that i think if florida
beats alabama
that that you would have a pretty strong
argument for two sec teams and then
absolutely if clemson like notre dame i
think is really close to being in
right now you know all they've got to do
is even with the loss
even with a loss as long as they don't
get dump trucked you know if it's
if it's a four touchdown loss and trevor
lawrence lights them up and you can say
oh that's the difference
uh then that may it may preclude them
but if it's if it's a close
game and they have beaten clemson once
and lost to them once i think they're
they're
pretty close to being in and i think
alabama same thing as long as
they could lose to florida as long as it
didn't 56
to nothing which it wouldn't be uh and i
think probably still get in as well
kyle trask the heisman it's his to lose
uh probably boy you know i me as a
heisman voter i i generally tend to wait
until the last minute and i want to see
everything but i mean he's been great
uh he was definitely the front runner
but you know zach wilson has been
awfully good at byu he just doesn't
quite have the platform
uh i still think trevor lawrence is the
best player uh
justin fields is running up against the
problem of of enough reps enough
performances enough stats uh i think
there's still enough
several people i want to look at for the
next couple of weeks before i decide
yeah i'm the same i'm a heisman voter as
well but if you would have said to me
two years ago trevor lawrence is going
to
leave clemson and not have a heisman
trophy
yeah shocking really you know i mean and
especially
hasn't been hurt and the team hasn't
lost you know that's that's the kind of
thing that
it it is very unusual to be in that
situation i
i still think he's going to get a lot of
votes uh this year i really do
but do you think that it that this would
be a career achievement award
for trevor lawrence in some people's
eyes it could be
it could be you know i mean he's having
a really good season he just he missed a
month he didn't there were two games
that he didn't play and then clemson
didn't play for a couple weeks
uh he's i believe ninth nationally and
pass efficiency he's doing well it's
just some other quarterbacks have had
more opportunities and done a lot with
them always great to talk to you pat
safe travels back home we appreciate
your time as always
my pleasure dan thank you that's pat
forty sports illustrated senior writer
covering college basketball
and college football